HERE'S HOPING.
ROBERT, THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
>> THANK YOU FOR HAVING ME.
>> Tucker: JASON NICHOLS IS
RIGHT IN THE MIDDLE OF THIS
DEBATE, AN ACTUAL PROFESSOR,
TEACHES AFRICAN-AMERICAN STUDIES
AT THE UNIVERSITY OF MARYLAND
PEER THANK YOU FOR COMING ON.
>> THANK YOU FOR HAVING ME.
>> Tucker: IT SEEMS LIKE A
BASELINE FOR UNIVERSITY TO HAVE
PRETTY MUCH ABSOLUTE FREEDOM OF
SPEECH, A PREREQUISITE FOR
FREEDOM OF THOUGHT.
WHAT IS THE POINT OF HAVING
COLLEGES IF YOU CAN'T SAY
WHATEVER YOU THINK?
>> I THINK NUMBER ONE, AND
SOCIETY, WE DON'T HAVE COMPLETE
FREEDOM OF SPEECH.
>> Tucker: TRUE.
>> THERE IS LIBEL, THERE IS
DEFAMATION, THERE ARE THREATS OF
VIOLENCE, AND INCITING VIOLENCE.
THOSE ARE LIMITS ON FREE SPEECH.
I THINK WE HAVE THIS IDEA THAT
FREEDOM OF SPEECH MEANS YOU CAN
SAY ANYTHING AT ANY TIME.
>> Tucker: NO, WE KNOW WHAT IT
IS, BECAUSE OF BRANDON VERSUS
OHIO IN 1967, THE FAMOUS
SUPREME COURT CASE, VERY
SPECIFICALLY OUTLINED THE
BOUNDARIES OF FREE SPEECH.
LIBEL IS NOT ALLOWED, OF COURSE,
IMMINENT THREATS OF VIOLENCE ARE
NOT ALLOWED.
EVERYTHING ELSE IS ALLOWED.
APPLE, AMAZON, OF SOME BIG
COMPANY -- COLLEGES EXIST TO BE
AN OASIS IN THE MIDDLE OF
COMMERCIAL SOCIETY FOR FREE
THINKING.
SO WHY WOULD THEY BE THE PLACES
WHERE FREETHINKING IS PUNISHED
MOST AGGRESSIVELY?
>> I AGREE THAT THERE ARE MANY
CASES -- YOU AND I ACTUALLY
DISCUSSED A CASE A LITTLE WHILE
AGO WHERE THERE WAS A COLLEGE
PROFESSOR WHO SAID SOMETHING HE
SHOULDN'T HAVE SAID, AND ALL OF
A SUDDEN, PEOPLE ARE TALKING
ABOUT HE NEEDS TO BE FIRED, THIS
IS WHY WE ACTUALLY HAVE TENURE,
TO PROTECT PEOPLE SO THEY CAN
SAY WHAT IT IS THEY WANT.
THERE HAVE BEEN ALL OF THESE
ATTACKS, PEOPLE TRYING TO PUT
LIMITS ON WHAT IT IS YOU SAY,
AND I THINK THAT IS PROBLEMATIC.
BUT, OVERALL, COLLEGES DO
PROTECT FREEDOM OF SPEECH.
>> Tucker: WHAT WOULD HAPPEN
IF YOU WENT INTO YOUR CLASS -- I
LIKE THAT DONALD TRUMP, AND WHAT
I LIKE ABOUT HIM?
I LIKE FAMILY SEPARATION, I LIKE
THE WALL, HE IS RIGHT THAT
MEXICO DOESN'T SEND US HIS BEST.
IF YOU READ PORTIONS OF A TRUMP
SPEECH.
HOW WOULD THAT WORK OUT?
>> I THINK STUDENTS WOULD
DISAGREE, AND THEY HAVE EVERY
RIGHT TO DISAGREE.
>> Tucker: OF COURSE THEY
WOULD COME I WOULD NEVER CONTEST
THEIR RIGHT.
>> EVEN IF THEY PROTESTED ME,
THAT IS PART OF THEIR
FIRST AMENDMENT RIGHT.
>> Tucker: YOU ARE GETTING NO
DEBATE FOR ME ON THAT.
I BELIEVE IN THE FREE EXCHANGE
OF IDEAS, AND DESPITE EFFORTS TO
SHUT US DOWN AND SHUT US UP,
WE'RE STILL DOING IT.
BUT IF YOU SAID THAT IN A
FACULTY MEETING, NO ONE WOULD
ENGAGE YOU.
PEOPLE WOULD JUST SAY, YOU KNOW
WHAT, I KNOW YOU ARE
AFRICAN-AMERICAN, BUT OBVIOUSLY
SOME KIND OF FREAKY BIGOT.
THEY WOULD TREAT YOU LIKE THEY
TREATED KANYE WEST.
NO ONE WOULD ENGAGE YOU AND SAY
TALK THROUGH THOSE IDEAS.
YOU REALLY THINK FAMILY
SEPARATION IS A GOOD IDEA?
NOW, THEY WOULD SHOUT AT YOU.
>> I THINK PEOPLE WOULD
DISAGREE, AND THEY WOULD HAVE
EVERY RIGHT TO DISAGREE.
>> Tucker: OF COURSE, THE
WHOLE IDEA COLLEGE AS YOU SAY
ONE THING, I SAY ANOTHER, THEN
WE TALK ABOUT THEM.
ISN'T THAT THE GOAL?
>> THE CONVERSATION DOESN'T
ALWAYS HAVE TO BE COMFORTABLE.
>> Tucker: OF COURSE NOT.
>> WE CAN YELL AT EACH OTHER, WE
CAN SIT THERE AND TRY TO SHUT
ONE ANOTHER DOWN, THAT IS PART
OF FREE SPEECH.
>> Tucker: OF COURSE, I GUESS
THE MACRO QUESTION IS HAVE YOU
EVER MET A GROUP OF PEOPLE WITH
SMALLER MIND THAN THOSE WHO
TEACH AND AMERICA'S COLLEGES?
LESS OPEN TO NEW IDEAS, TO
CHALLENGING, TRULY CHALLENGING
CONCEPTS?
>> THAT IS LITERALLY WHAT WE DO
ON COLLEGE CAMPUSES, CHALLENGE
CONCEPTS AND POPULAR IDEAS.
>> Tucker: WHEN YOU GO TO YOUR
NEXT FACULTY MEETING, JUST SAY,
FOR THE RECORD, ABORTION IS
MURDER.
AT [LAUGHS]
I WANT TO SEE HOW THAT WORKS.
>> EVERY SEMESTER, WE HAVE
ABORTION ACTIVISTS WHO COME OUT
AND LITTER THE CAMPUS WITH
PICTURES OF ABORTED FETUSES,
PREGNANT WOMEN WALKING ACROSS
CAMPUS CRYING AND ALL OF THESE
KIND OF THINGS.
IT IS STILL THERE
FIRST AMENDMENT RIGHT.
>> Tucker: OF COURSE IT IS.
PEOPLE COMPLAIN, BUT WHAT WOULD
YOUR COLLEAGUES SAY IF YOU SAID
THAT?
>> I'M SURE THEY WOULD BE
DISGUSTED AND UPSET WITH ME,
SOMEWHAT.
THEY DON'T HAVE TO BE OPEN --
>> Tucker: BUT THEY SHOULD BE.
THEY ARE NOT SUPPOSED TO BE
SMALL MINDED, THEIRS WAS TO BE
BROAD-MINDED.
>> THESE ARE PEOPLE WHO ARE
PROBABLY STUDIED THE ISSUE --
>> Tucker: NO THEY HAVEN'T!
>> PEOPLE STUDY FOR A LIVING.
>> Tucker: THAT IS THE IRONY